DEMOCRATIC GRIEF.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
THIS MAY SEEM STRANGE TO YOU BUT
I'M HERE TONIGHT TO COUNSEL
DEMOCRATS TO HELP THEM.
YES, YOU HEARD RIGHT.
TO HELP.
SINCE SIMILAR REPORT WAS HANDED
DOWN, MILLIONS OF LIBERALS
ACROSS AMERICA HAVE BEEN
SUFFERING FROM A PROFOUND SENSE
OF LOSS.
THESE FEELINGS AT TIMES SEEM
OVERWHELMING.
>> CALM DOWN.
BREATHE, BREATHE.
WHAT DID THE BAD MAN DO?
>> [SCREAMING]
[SEVEN]
>> Laura: BLESS THEIR HEARTS.
THEY HAVE INVESTED SO MUCH OF
THEMSELVES INTO THEIR FUTURES IN
ROBERT MUELLER TAKING ON THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY NAMED THEIR DOGS AFTER HIM.
THEY LIT CANDLES FOR HIM.
THEY EVEN WORE HIS NAME.
THEY VENERATED HIM.
AND THEY GAVE HIM THANKS.
>> THANK YOU, ROBERT MUELLER AND
EVERYONE WORKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE SOVEREIGNTY FOR THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Laura: YOU SEE, MUELLER
WASN'T JUST A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
TO DEMOCRATS.
HE WAS A DAT, A MESSIAH-LIKE
FIGURE WHO WOULD DELIVER THEM FR
FIGURE WHO WOULD DELIVER THEM FM
THE EVIL OF TRUMP AND
WASH AWAY THE SIN OF THE 2016
ELECTION.
LET'S FACE IT.
EVEN THOUGH BUILT ON RAGE, THIS
WAS A RELIGION FOR THE LEFT, AND
NOW WITH THE RESULTS IN AN
MR. MUELLER RETURNING TO PRIVATE
LIFE, LEFTISTS OF ALL AGES ARE
ASKING THEMSELVES WHO WILL
REPLACE HIM?
WHAT TO LOOK FORWARD TO NOW THAT
IT'S ALL OVER.
HOW TO GO BACK TO NORMAL LIFE
WITHOUT THE EXCITEMENT OF THE
INVESTIGATION UNFOLDING DAY
AFTER DAY.
WHAT WILL FILL THE VOID?
WELL, RECOVERY WON'T BE EASY.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE TO YOU.
FOR DEMOCRATS, THE END OF THIS
INVESTIGATION IS AKIN TO THE
DEATH OF A LOVED ONE.
THEY WILL NEED TO DEVELOP COPING
MECHANISMS AND DO A LOT OF
INTERIOR WORK.
ONLY THEN WILL THEY TRUMP-HATERS
BE ABLE TO PUT THEIR LOSS INTO
PERSPECTIVE.
AND THEN MOVE ON.
AUTHORS DAVID KESSLER AND
ELIZABETH TO BARAJAS HAVE
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUTC
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUTP
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUTN
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUTG
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUTW
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUTT
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUTH
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUTA
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUTI
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUTC
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUTL
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUTS
WRITTEN A NUMBER OF BOOKS ABOUT.
THEY BROKE IT DOWN INTO FIVE
STAGES.
WE SEE THE DEMOCRATS AND THEY
TRUMP-HATERS WORKING THEIR WAY
THROUGH THE GRIEVING PROCESS.
STAGE ONE: DENIAL.
>> I DON'T BUY THAT HE'S
COMPLETELY EXONERATED THE WAY HE
JUST SAID.
>> AFTER TWO YEARS, IF YOU STILL
HAVE QUESTIONS, YOU STILL CAN'T
ANSWER THAT QUESTION, IT'S NOT
GOOD ENOUGH TO SAY WHEN YOU
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT HE'S
COMMITTED A CRIME.
>> THIS IS THE START OF
SOMETHING APPARENTLY, NOT THE
END OF SOMETHING.
>> SO MUCH THAT NEEDS TO BE, YOU
KNOW, TAKE A LOOK AT AT THIS
POINT.
>> THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHETHER THERE IS
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION AND I
THINK THAT EVIDENCE IS IN PLAIN
SIGHT.
>> Laura: AND AFTER DENIAL
COMES STAGE TWO.
ANGER.
>> WHY WAS THERE NEVER
INTERROGATION OF THIS PRESIDENT?
HOW CAN THEY LET TRUMP OFF THE
HOOK?
>> AND ANY OTHER STANDARD, THE
PERSON WOULD'VE BEEN ARRESTED.
THEY WOULD'VE BEEN POLYGRAPH
DONE PUT OUT OR BROUGHT TO DEBT
TRAP.
>> THERE'S NOT AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN PERSON IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT COULD'VE BEEN
INVESTIGATED FOR 22 MONTHS, HAD
THEIR FAMILY INVESTIGATED FOR 22
MONTHS, AND COME OFF SCOT-FREE.
>> IT FEELS LIKE THE SEEDS EVE
>> IT FEELS LIKE THE SEEDS EVR
COVER UP HER HERE.
>> Laura: LET IT OUT.
WE UNDERSTAND.
YOU SPENT TWO YEARS LIVING IN A
FANTASY WORLD OF YOUR OWN
MAKING.
AFTER ANGER COMES PERHAPS
GRIEF'S MOST EMBARRASSING STAYED
WHERE THEY TRIED TO CONVINCE
THEMSELVES THAT UP IS DOWN,
BLACK IS WHITE, AND TRUMP IS
GUILTY.
IT'S CALLED BARGAINING.
>> THE MUELLER REPORT WILL
ULTIMATELY GET OUT AND THERE
WILL BE DAMAGING INFORMATION FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
>> THAT WAS A FINDING.
MUELLER DID NOT EXONERATE THIS
PRESIDENT.
>> WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL WHAT IT
SAYS.
IT DOESN'T MEAN TRUMP IS FREE
AND CLEAR.
>> Laura: BARGAINING IS SORT
OF THE LAST GASP OF A DYING
FANTASY BUT THE FACT IS MUELLER
DID NOT FIND ANY EVIDENCE OF
MUCH OF THE BALLYHOO TRUMP
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA.
IT JUST DIDN'T HAPPEN.
I KNOW IT'S HARD.
WHICH BRINGS US TO STAGE FOUR.
DEPRESSION.
>> THIS WEEKEND, WE RECEIVED
SOME TROUBLING NEWS.
OUR PRESIDENT IS NOT A RUSSIAN
ASSET.
>> OBVIOUSLY RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
MOSTLY JUST A TON OF QUESTIONS
AS TO WHAT MUELLER'S REPORT
SAYS, HOW COMPLETE IT IS, WHO
GETS TO SEE IT, WHO GETS TO
DECIDE WHO GETS TO SEE IT, AND
WHEN.
>> THERE'S AN HONEST LEVEL OF
SADNESS AND DISAPPOINTMENT AND
DISORIENTATION AMONG
PROGRESSIVES AND DEMOCRATS.
I THINK IT GOES DEEPER THAN
JUST, YOU KNOW, WHAT'S IN THE
REPORTS.
>> Laura: AS SAD AS IT IS, THE
NEXT LEVEL OF GRIEF IS PERHAPS
THE MOST IMPORTANT.
STAGE FIVE: ACCEPTANCE.
THIS IS WHERE LIBERALS ARE IN
REAL TROUBLE BECAUSE FOR THEM,
THERE IS NO ACCEPTANCE OF THE
MUELLER FINDINGS.
THERE CAN'T BE.
THEY OPT INSTEAD FOR VENGEANCE.
>> ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR SHOULD
BE REQUIRED TO TESTIFY BEFORE
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS UNDER
OATH.
>> HE SHOULD COME BEFORE THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS.
I DO NOT DEEPLY RESPECT AND
TRUST THE BARR SUMMARY.
>> I WILL CERTAINLY RECOMMEND
THAT WE BRING BOB MUELLER IN TO
TESTIFY, THAT WE TAKE IT TO
COURT IF NECESSARY.
>> Laura: OKAY, SO MANY OF
THEM JUST WILL NOT ACCEPT THIS
LOSS.
BUT REBECCA DUDLEY CERTAINLY
DOES.
REMEMBER, SHE WAS THE WOMAN WHO
COCREATED THIS BUTTON AND SOLD
MORE THAN 48,000 OF THEM TO
LIBERALS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
WHO SAID FAITH WAS DEAD?
SHE TOLD "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
THIS WEEK OF THE MUELLER REPORT
THAT "SHE KNEW THERE WAS NO WAY
ANYTHING COULD LIVE UP TO TWO
YEARS OF HYPE."
SO SHE'S THINKING OF CREATING A
NEW BUTTON TO RESTORE HOPE IN
THE HEARTS OF LEFTISTS
EVERYWHERE.
>> IT WILL READ ST NY, AS IN
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.